he's tappy out part of this lecture
people quit sometimes
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show without
questions and even hotter wings
and today I'm joined by Casey nice that
he's at YouTube juggernaut technologist
and filmmaker with clout through the
roof but the whole house of cards could
come crashing down today if the man taps
out before explain that Graham Casey
welcome to the show I'm definitely gonna
tap out before explaining that Graham
how are you with hot food I guess not
I'm not good I'm not good I'm ready I'm
psyched I've been training a little bit
but I'm not good well you ready get
going I've never been we're ready for
anything in my entire life
[Music]
all right so this first one is Valentina
I'm starting on the same side here yeah
yes yes yes okay
like you'd read a book not want to start
on the wrong side I understood why no I
wanna [ __ ] the top ranked this is life
this is nice this is like somebody give
me a nice warm hug so I want to start by
taking it back to the pre blog days when
you were working as a dishwasher and
what you've described as a shitty
seafood restaurant in Southeast
Connecticut what do you remember about
that job because kitchens aren't really
known for having the healthiest work
environments no it's like the shittiest
work environment and I always say that
like if you don't know what you want to
do in life spend as much time as
possible doing something [ __ ] hate
doing because my job is a pot washer so
I'd have to scrub the bottom of huge
sauce pot we cook clam chowder why don't
you do that 50 hours a week you spent a
lot of time thank me about what you wish
you were doing so I say that like so
much of my sort of ambitions in life and
my goals in life my dreams are life were
born from the bottom of that shitty
chowder pot I think I just [ __ ] up an
eight number three sauce instead of the
number two sauce he definitely [ __ ] up
what do we do have to cancel the whole
shoot no no sorry turn everything off I
think it's an interchangeable sort of
life not like I went from two to ten
right right right
Jerry from three to two maintaining eye
contact and I skipped a wing you got a
little fancy got a little cocky out
there that was it that's because that's
a strong two right there
so you've stacked almost two billion
views eight million subscribers and
created a genre all your own but I
imagine that the accomplishment that
you're perhaps most proud of is getting
the mayor of New York to discuss biker
lane laws after doing a video fighting
that ticket so I gotta take
but often there are obstructions that
keep you
probably riding in the bike
and I wonder is someone who's often
thumbed their nose at Authority does
that video in particular hold a special
place in your heart yeah I you know like
that bike lanes but you always say I
made that says really pissed off I gotta
take it for for something I shouldn't
have gotten a ticket for so I use my
video camera in YouTube as a way of sort
of speaking out against that of
expressing my frustration and then the
end I kind of got some retribution so
like it brings me back to my teenage
years when I was always in trouble in
school but nobody would ever listen to
me you know you do a lot of insane
things in your videos whether it's you
know hanging from a drone or
skateboarding behind a Lamborghini and
all those shoots when were you most
fearful for your life like last year for
Christmas when we built the only drone
in the world that could carry a human
being and it had me 200 feet in the air
I had a microphone on those directing my
cameramen and the drone operator so
you'd listen to the audio and it's not a
fearful one I'm literally screaming
higher higher higher Brett are you
getting the shot so as long as your
brain somewhere else like that stuff
doesn't really spook me so much when I'm
the director my focus is on getting the
shot more so than it is preservation of
life
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can make a case now that vloggers
are the voice of the people and nowhere
is that more apparent than in your
approach to food whether it's chasing
down carryout with Lucky Charms or
grilled cheese days are very diplomatic
and dining so I'm gonna hit you with a
quick food rapid-fire plate I mean it of
all your globe-trotting adventures
what's the International fast food menu
item that stands out in Singapore and I
think they have this all over Asia but
McDonald's has their hot up the pies and
instead of filled up with delicious
cinnamon apple goo it's filled up with
this florescent taro taro goo I don't
know what taro or taro is if it wasn't
you're eating a deep-fried sock filled
up with purple goo that is not my go-to
but that's one that really stands out I
think international fast food what's the
most underrated food specialty from
Connecticut steamed cheeseburgers
absolutely not the most underrated food
item from Connecticut is I think it's
now called Connecticut style lobster
rolls Connecticut style is the grilled
bun but they just take lobs for me to
put butter over it it's the most amazing
thing that Connecticut has ever yielded
since the big millionaire is the
Constitution or the Declaration of
Independence that came from Connecticut
there are eight people in this room and
none of them are that smart and none of
them are that smart it's one of the
greatest contributions that Connecticut
has ever made the world is the
Connecticut style lobster roll
[Music]
there's a nice sauce this is a sleeper
isn't it oh yeah lingers okay ah and as
somebody who's stacked views against
changing platforms and algorithms I
wonder how you think the viral video has
evolved since the Kimbo Slice days
virality used to have a little bit more
authenticity to it and now virality is
much more hackable there's a whole
vlogger movement right now and what
these vloggers do is they create hip-hop
videos that are typically dis tracks and
these are individuals with no background
of music at all and they create these
songs that take somebody else down the
song was hugely viral forfor myriad
reasons and that is a way of sort of
hacking the system to make something go
viral
then they'll do 100 million views and a
lot of that will push over their channel
it's a way to grow the channel and then
the whole network piles on top of that
so I think that viral videos can be
approached a little bit more
systematically now versus eight ten
years ago which is like it had to be
something that nobody had seen before if
you were gonna start piecemealing
together a timeline for viral videos
that you think were may be game changers
in the genre or watershed moments where
does your mind wander justin.tv which
however long really decided to broadcast
an entire life I think is really really
interesting at the time he was doing
that reality TV was these really
sculpted shows like the real world and I
think that had a big part in leading
into vlogging and I think that vlogging
has now become the new norm as far as
reality television I think that Gangnam
style when you think about like success
in music even shifting away from other
mediums like radio and things like that
Gangnam style really brought that to
YouTube in a way nothing had ever done
before I'm completely lost train of
thoughts my mouth is really hot right
now doing wings when you're not doing
the self but no were you a wing guy
before the show I mean who isn't at some
level whatever but like at this point
like you know it's hard for me to even
look at a chicken wing I wouldn't know
it you really look like you're enjoying
yourself
I'm blessed to have this like goofball
job like this cartoon existence that I
have going but I remind myself of that
every single morning by the way all
right Casey so every current segment on
our show called explain that Graham we
do a deep dive and I guess Instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll show you the picture and
then you just tell me the bigger spread
that sound good
laptop please let the record show new
laptop four years with the company
finally got an air that's like a two
year old model yeah all right Casey
first things first met gallop with
Karlie Kloss I was very uncomfortable
there so I just hung out on the red
carpet I don't think I'll ever be
invited back just let me be totally
clear on that Miz went or if you're
seeing this I would appreciate another
invitation but I've respect if if I've
been banished for life I really like
wandering around inside like a little
kid with my camera like trying to find
stuff to film but it's like kid film
those people know who Taylor Swift walk
by me would like to her phalanx of
security just like giving me a stink
face at a camera on me and then they had
these long banisters in the Met and
there's like nobody they look to whoever
you wanna get the models smoking
cigarettes in the bathroom so I was like
sliding down the banister just for shits
and giggles and at the end of like
tumbled off and fell like landed at
Derek Jeter's feet no this one's nuts
this is nuts and that's very real so I
moved to New York City like June 1st or
something like that
2001 my three months sublease was up
September 1 2001 so I moved on to a
friend's couch which was like one block
underneath the World Trade Centers I got
out of there where after the first plane
hit it actually was knocked off my bike
when the second plane hit says Renner
Neath it falling debris the whole thing
but my apartment was destroyed and I had
nothing so they had shut off everything
I mean south of Canal Street the next
day and it literally had Humvees that he
couldn't penetrate so I I put on like a
contractor vest and a helmet and I went
down there and said as a contractor so
they let me by and I could break into my
own apartment to get clothes and that
picture is a picture of me on my way to
breaking into my apartment all right so
this next one is dirty dicks
they're aggressive brand-name you guys
cook please here no we get them from a
carry-out joint but I would
to point out you know we used to have
bad wings and they used to be kind of
cold and when it was cold people and the
Catholic they freaked out freaked out so
mad at us that's like sacrilege right
yeah but you know it's logistical II
kind of complicated to like do this
whatever cuz you know like carry heat
them get reheat them and then it's like
you Mike people you light people like
whatever like I was twenty five minutes
late right lots of variables and people
are not forgiving they don't give you a
long leash on that but we have done a
lot to ensure that and turn that around
and now we're serving up restaurant
quality wings usually a bit on the
warmer side sometimes even oven hot and
not one compliment no one has ever Pat
us on the back for no-one's ever like
hey hot ones
big improvement way to come back from
that nobody says anything yeah these are
great these are just above room
temperature is that that that's the
first thing I finish so as your fans
know you're an avid runner sometimes
stack in eighty miles a week I know that
you've done for Ironman is there a
personal record that you're most proud
of
no I'm ashamed of my personal record the
Holy Grail is to break three hours in a
marathon and I've run under 305 as in
within five minutes of my target like
twelve times in a row I've even run like
302 multiple occasions and the fact that
over three hours 26 miles I can't shave
two [ __ ] minutes is infuriating
where's the weirdest place that you've
ever gone to the bathroom and the throes
of a 16-hour race to stop your bike
that's minutes you know slow all the way
down and speed all the way back up too
much to ask way too much to ask so you
just kind of go you just let it flow you
just let it go
[Music]
well that's nice oh no no I said me
mm-hmm
[Music]
okay at the first time can you hit the
water listen I'm no superhero
so round here we're always talking about
traditional media versus the new guard
and you have such unique perspective for
somebody who said [ __ ] it and fled HBO
and ran to YouTube and I wonder is
someone who is on both sides of the coin
why do you prefer the Internet to a TV
deal this is where creativity is headed
and I think it's overall a very positive
thing when I created my TV show here's
my brother van and I we made the whole
show ourselves
and in between us finishing the show
saying this is done we're ready to show
this of the world in the world actually
seeing in the audience were producers
and agents and the head of production
and the this production person and then
this executive and then all of these
filters and the magic of YouTube is that
when I say something's done I just click
upload and it goes out to the audience
when you see something on television you
know that there's that big filtration
process and and losing that was probably
the most exciting part of becoming a
youtuber because I don't know like it's
a it's a thing that comes up even with
like this show all the time where I
always feel like people are trying to
shove it into some deep cable spot or
something and I'm kind of like well you
know what the hell like that's not
really how the scales are tippy TV like
is objectively fading it's like that's
not an opinion it's falling so that
elevators going down down down down down
the Internet's going up up up up up so
why would you possibly jump on that
elevator car that's headed down even if
it's a little higher when you know
you're headed in the right direction and
that's how I see TV how do you respond
to critics who think you're just as
deeply in the pockets of brands as these
traditional media outlets I mean the
short answer is sort of like [ __ ] them
and I don't I don't mean to say like
[ __ ] the audience or anything like that
I really respect the audience but I do
think that there's this false sense of
altruism online if you're a YouTube
creator making money off of what you do
should be shun for a youtuber to make a
living off of what they're doing is
something that like
they should be embarrassed up and I
don't I don't agree with that at all
so if the audience doesn't get that then
you know I'm much more dismissive I
don't feel like I need to apologize I
also don't feel like I need to make them
be okay with it
my head is sweating yeah yeah like I'm
sweating through my hair right now
got a glisten
I see other creators making a living
resi jig Paul buy a Lamborghini I'm just
like [ __ ] yeah man way to do it but it
takes something you know I'm having
trouble with this I'm bonfire over here
can you give me an idiot's guide to the
great demonetized candle raging right
now yeah and this is gonna surprise you
but I side with YouTube a little bit as
much as vocal as I've been against
YouTube in the D monetization scandal I
do side with YouTube YouTube is this is
this gigantic outlet of content where 40
hours of videos uploaded every minute of
every day every day of the year there's
no way a human can monitor all of that
the only way they make money to support
this gigantic infrastructure is by
selling ads against that video content
so like you know when when I was trying
to think of a milk company the Dairy
Farmers of America so when the Dairy
Farmers of America buy ads on YouTube
and they're showing up in front of
videos that show you know cows being
slaughtered or something like that
of course the dairy farmers gonna be
pissed off so YouTube's trying their
very best to you know to look after the
brands are spending money to make sure
that their business is viable but the
repercussions of that when it's all
machine learning behind it is that
they're gonna be mistakes and the
unfortunate part of those mistakes is
that they cost youtubers
actual money who's really spicy I am
trying trying to hold it down that last
one really [ __ ] me up good though who
the bomb beyond insanity
cheers Cheers so that one just gets
right over the flavor and just goes
right to the heat huh not a lot of
nuance there I just
this proof force is what it is yeah as
someone who's traveled the world which
city or country treats its tourists like
family can't repeat the question where
that you've traveled do they treat
tourists the best he's tapping out part
of this like the people quit sometimes
[Music]
I'm trying to think I've definitely been
careful around your eyes Casey why like
9:00 to 10:00 jump there is huge I've
definitely been places where they're so
appreciative that you're there this is
me that they're really nice see because
well which country do you want to travel
back to just to have the food again my
favorite place in the world South Africa
because the food there's not that far
off get great steaks and cheeseburgers
and chicken peri-peri and all kinds of
[ __ ] like that but it's the southern
hemisphere so like we're drinking then
the cow is a breathing different
aerating taste different everything
tastes better are you are you okay you
know I'm okay if you're okay I've never
mmm of all the crazy hotel rooms that
you've stayed in which one stands out
easy The Fairmont in San Francisco but
they have this room where the presidents
stay then I ve just meant for me to like
look in they're not staying there but
it's like 3,000 4,000 square feet and
has all these secret entrances and
there's like a dome with a library the
secret entrance like JFK used to sneak
his concubines in and out of
so this next one is Blair's Megadeth
sauce with liquid rage I just want to be
clear you decided went over that quickly
yeah
Blair's Megadeth sauce hold it hold with
liquid rage
[Music]
well I am I'm okay I'm not trying to be
a dick but do hardcore skaters give you
[ __ ] about the electric skateboard yes
they like make fun of me like the nerd
in rollerblades in the skate park that's
how they make fun of me when they see me
on my electric skateboard and my
response to them is like spicy my
sponsor theme is I also ride a bike and
I'm really good on a bike it doesn't
mean I don't love a motorcycle
I love to skate it doesn't mean I don't
love the electric skateboard there are
two different monsters what was more fun
skateboarding behind Lamborghini and
Dubai or when you were cutting through a
blizzard in Manhattan with the help of
the NYPD Oh snowboarding in New York
City was one of the greatest days ever
that truck was built just so no amount
of snow could stop it and I needed a
storm where the NYPD couldn't drive
their patrol cars but I could drive my
truck spicy so on that day and that day
none of the cops could keep up with us
we just bomb around the city going 35
snowboarding and then thrown their
sirens they like spinning single tire
and then just wave us by there's like a
really satisfying day all right Casey
thanks for having me today I was built
as a pleasure to be here
this is the last dab you call it the
last dab because it's tradition around
here it's a put a little extra on the
last wing you don't have to if you don't
want to Casey nice that yeah of course I
wanted to [ __ ] love this stuff this
spicy a little bit
Wow yeah yeah yeah yeah good dramatic
effect cheers Cheers fun nice flavor
earthy very earthy and meaty
further questions here well Casey I only
have one more question for you here we
are at wing 10 and you're still standing
I wouldn't expect less from somebody who
has do more tattooed on one arm and work
harder on the other so now with the
scovilles going through you we need you
to hit one more truth bomb what do you
say to the would-be creatives out there
who are waiting around for somebody else
to pay for their opus oh I get your head
of your ass I mean we have never
especially when it comes to film you
know the thing I would say about making
movies you want to be a writer and you
depend on a piece of paper if you want
to be a painter needs paint in a canvas
but historically making videos has been
this untouchable things it's so
expensive and now if you have a cell
phone in your pocket in an internet
connection you can film a movie and then
distribute to the world creators like
people have never been more empowered to
share their ideas and vision via video
as they are right now like there are no
more excuses there's like sweat pouring
down the back of my look at that water
do you see that glistening remarkable
glistening shining I feel like I'm
looking at a superhero across the table
Casey nice dad
now Casey there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend
this camera this camera at this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life right now my mouth is on
fire no I would say um you know
subscribe to my youtube channel I just
want to do more of what I'm doing right
now I just want to do it and do more of
it that's the vision for 2018
[Music]
it's just like really wreaking havoc hmm
imagine me me how the hell you do this
holy [ __ ]
hello hot ones fans it's Sean Evans new
outro same message if you like what you
saw throw us a bone maybe please it is
dog-eat-dog here on the YouTube streets
hit that subscribe button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning
thank you very much hot ones fans I love
you